Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Ali Alicci. Auch diese Station als Diensthabender
Arztätik und ich würde gerne jetzt mit Ihnen das Untersuchung aufnahme,
Untersuchung, Gespräch führen. Sind Sie damit verstanden? Ja, Herr Doktor, gerne.
Okay, so heißt es. Wie heißen Sie? Mein Name ist Franz Josef Strauss. Strauss ist der Nachname.
Ein bisschen anderes Name. Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachnamebuch stabilen?
Ja, der Nachname ist Strauss. S-T-R-A-U. Scharfes S. Ja. Und Vorname ist Franz Josef. Franz-F-R-A-N-Z.
Bin ich drehig. Josef-J-O-S-E-F. Franz Josef. Ja, danke schön. Herr Strauss, wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ja, ich bin 70 Jahre alt. Wie groß sind Sie? Ungefähr 1,80 m, war ich mal. Und wie viel wiegern Sie sind?
Ungefähr 110 kg. Und wann wurde unser ganz genau geboren? Geboren? Ja.
Herr Strauss, 5. Juli 1952. Danke schön für die Information. Herr Strauss, was kann ich versuchen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe zunehmend Problem der Luft. Also, wie Sie hören, kann ich ganz schwer atmen.
Und seit zweiter Tagen ist es so, dass ich bis zur Toilette gehen kann.
Und dann habe ich Luftnot, dann kann ich nicht mehr weiterlaufen. Also, es ist extrem kurzatmig.
Okay, ich verstehe. Herr Strauss. Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie die Beschwerden auch treten sind?
Ja, so. Vorher haben Sie eine Grip-Sentome gehabt oder so plötzlich es kommt, oder?
Also, ich muss dazu sagen, ich habe schon lange Zeit Probleme in der Luft. Aber seit zwei, drei Tagen ist es so, dass ich da bei der geringsten Bewegung Atemnot bekomme.
Das war vorher nicht so. Und seit drei Tagen ruft sich auch stark. Und ich habe auch viel Auswurf.
Wie leiden unter irgendwelche chronischen Krankheiten?
Aber da habe ich viel, Herr Doktor. Wo soll ich da anfangen?
Ja, vielleicht können die Lungen betroffenen Krankheiten anfangen.
Ja, also wie die Lunge ist es so, dass wegen dem Rauchen ich diese COPD-Krankheit wohl habe, hat Herr Doktor gesagt.
Aber auch schon ziemlich lange. Also seit ungefähr 10, 15 Jahren nehme ich da auch Medikamente ein.
10 Jahre, bestimmt schon. 10, 15?
10 Jahre, mindestens ja. 10 Jahre schon, ja.
Und am Anfang war es nicht so schlimm. Da habe ich nur ein bisschen Probleme gehabt.
In den letzten Jahren ist es immer schlechter geworden mit der Luft.
Leider sind da auch irgendwelche chronischen Krankheiten?
Herzkrankheiten?
Herz habe ich auch Probleme gehabt. Vor fünf Jahren hatte ich so ähnlich wie ein Herzinfarkt,
haben die gesagt und da habe ich ein Herzkette bekommen und ein Stent.
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Okay.
Dann habe ich Bluthochdruck.
Ja.
Und dann hatte ich Bluthochdruck.
Da nehme ich schon seit auch schon über 10 Jahre Medikamente ein.
sogar länger, 15 Jahre Doktor.
Ja. Herr Strauss, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt?
Brauchen Sie also Sauerstoff?
Oder die schlimmsten Tiere?
Ja, also ich merke schon, wenn ich mit Ihnen rede, wird es auch schon knapp mit der Luft.
Sauerstoff wäre ganz gut, glaube ich.
Okay, mache ich das?
Ich möchte diese Gespräche jetzt beenden.
Und Ihre Vitalparameter, ja, Lebewahrter überprüfen.
Dann können wir diese Gespräche weiterführen.
Okay, einfach dann, Herr Doktor.
Ja.
Jetzt habe ich das erledigt.
Okay.
Herr Strauss, ich sehe an, Sie sehen ganz gut aus jetzt.
Neiden Sie an irgendwelche Schmerzen auch?
Nein, Herr Doktor, ich kann nichts sagen.
Taubheit, Grimbegefühl oder Seeprobleme?
Mit Seen habe ich, wie haben Sie das noch gefragt?
Mit Seen ist alles okay.
Taubheit, Arm, Beinen?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Ich dachte, dass ich nicht gut hören kann.
Taubheit an den Händen?
Händen, Fuseln, können auch Beinen sein.
Grimbegefühl auch?
Gribbel habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie sich fibrig?
Ich habe keine Fieber gemessen, aber so würde ich sagen, eher nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Übelkeit, Ebrüschen?
Nein, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Hat sich Ihr Appetit in der Lesterzeit verändert?
Ja, in den letzten drei Tagen geht es mir nicht gut, der esse ich auch nicht mehr so viel.
Das stimmt ja.
Aber vorher hatte ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit Gewichtveränderungen?
Ab oder so genommen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe mich nicht gewogen, muss ich sagen.
Meine Hosen passen noch wie vorher.
Okay.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Gewichtveränderungen haben.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlasseln?
Eigentlich keine großen Probleme, nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Husternsee?
Ja, Herr Doktor, jetzt zunehmend.
Letzten drei Tagen habe ich doch starken Husten, ja.
Und kommt auch etwas raus, wenn ich Huste.
Mit Schleimig, meinen Sie?
Ja.
Welche Inkonsistenz und Farbe?
Die Konsistenz weiß ich nicht, aber Farbe ist so gelb, manchmal grün nicht so.
Konsistenz, also, was ist da drin, ja?
Also wie flüssig oder so hart?
Das ist ganz normaler C.L. Schleim, so wie es oft ist.
Die Farbe, gelb, haben Sie gesagt?
Gelb ist noch leicht grün nicht, war es auch mal gewesen.
Ein paar Mal.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie auch Abschlagenheit?
Ja, ich fühle mich, ja.
Wie gesagt, ich kann zur Toilette gehen, dann muss ich mich ausrunden.
Ich kriege keinen Luft mehr.
Okay.
Wie viel?
Auch, also meine Treppen.
Ohne Pause, Treppen.
Treppen steigen, ich schaffe gar nicht momentan.
Momentan geht gar nicht.
Ich bin ja jetzt mit dem Krankenpanzgott hergefahren worden.
Also ich kann gerade auslaufen bis zur Toilette,
aber Treppen steigen kann ich nicht momentan.
Herr Strauss, rauchen Sie?
Ich habe aufgehört vor fünf Jahren,
als ich diese Herzkrankheit hatte.
Wie viele Jahre und was haben Sie geraucht?
Also ich habe lange geraucht.
Es waren so ein bis anderthalb Päckchen.
Und ich habe vor fünf Jahren aufgehört, also mit 65 Jahren
habe ich aufgehört.
Angefangen habe ich mit ja vielleicht 15 Jahren.
Also bestimmt 50 Jahre habe ich geraucht.
Ungefähr täglich ein anderthalb Päckchen.
Das ist vielleicht eine ganze Zigaretten.
Ja, Zigaretten habe ich geraucht.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Fast nie.
Also früher mal, aber seit auch fünf Jahren triege ich kein Alkohol.
Haben Sie früher getrunken?
Ja, früher habe ich mal ein Bier pro Tag getrunken,
aber auch nicht so viel.
Also seit wann haben Sie auch getrunken?
Also trinken Sie nicht mehr?
Also ich trinke schon noch, aber sehr selten.
Also vielleicht einmal in der Woche.
Seit fünf Jahren habe ich das reduziert.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Strauss, bitte nehmen Sie diese Fragen nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Konzernieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Strauss, Sie haben erzählt,
dass Sie Lungen, Herzen und Polutochdruck haben.
Haben Sie auch andere Vorerkrankungen
oder wichtige Krankungen?
Ja, ich habe Zucker.
Zucker habe ich, Herr Doktor.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie das?
Ja, ich nehme mich auch schon fast seit sieben, acht Jahren Medikamente ein.
Und dann habe ich noch letztes Jahr, habe ich ein Wirbelbruch gehabt.
Wirbelkörperbruch, das war spontan, da war ich im Krankenhaus.
Dann haben die gesagt, ich habe auch Theroporose auch.
Das war Bruch, ne?
Ja, Lendenwirbelkörper, fünf.
Und dann haben Sie auch noch einen Bruch.
Haben Sie Operiten?
Nein, das haben die so nur beobachtet,
mit Schmerzmedikamenten, dann ist es jetzt auch besser geworden.
Okay.
Noch etwas.
Ich meine, haben Sie schon Operiten?
Als Kind habe ich mal ein Blindermoperation gehabt.
Ansonsten keine anderen Operation,
außer jetzt diese Herzgeschichte.
Wie hören Sie sich?
Wie alt waren Sie sich?
Beim Blinderm?
Ja.
13, 14 vielleicht.
Okay.
Herr Strauss, Sie sind so vorständig geliebt.
Ich meine auch gegen Corona.
Gegen Corona habe ich Impfung, ja.
Wahnsinn, der Lesterzeit ging im Ausland?
Oder haben Sie eine Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich war seit vielen Jahren nicht im Ausland,
seit zehn Jahren bestimmt schon.
Okay.
Fühlen Sie Ihre Beinschwellung?
Oder haben Sie bemerkt?
Beinschwellung habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Treiben Sie Sport, Herr Strauss?
Ich treibe keinen Sport.
Ich bin zu schwach dafür, glaube ich.
Ich treibe keinen Sport, ja?
Nein.
Okay.
Herr Strauss, ich möchte über Ihre Familien an der Mirse ein bisschen leben,
Ihren Eltern noch?
Nein, mein Eltern sind schon gestorben.
Erden Sie sich?
Woran müssen Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte Lungenkrebs, der hat auch viel Zigaretten geraucht leider.
Und meine Mutter hatte auch verschiedene Krankheiten,
die dann am Schlaganfall gestorben.
Haben Sie Bruder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Geschwister, ja.
Sind Sie krank oder leiden Sie auch irgendeine wunderschöne Krankheit?
Ich habe wenig Kontakt, ich kann Sie nicht sagen, Herr Doktor.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Herr Strauss, ich denke, Sie sind so seit Ihnen Renten?
Ja, richtig.
Was haben Sie vorher als Beruf gemacht, beruflich gemacht?
Also ich habe verschiedene Sachen gemacht,
zuletzt war ich Lagerarbeiter, in einem Lager gearbeitet.
Danke.
Okay, ich habe vergessen,
was Sie so seit Benut oder eingenommen haben als Medikament.
Da habe ich ganz viele.
Ich habe eine Liste dabei.
Ich habe eine Liste, ich kann mal kurz die Liste mal auspacken.
Ja, das sage ich auch.
Also einmal nehme ich AS100, dann habe ich Atowastatin 20.
Also AS nehmen Sie morgen, ja.
Atowastatin nehme ich abends.
Dann habe ich Ramipril, 5 morgens eine.
Und Atowastatin, wie ist die Dosierung?
20, 20, ja.
Atowastatin, Ramipril nehmen Sie morgen, ein Mark.
Eine morgens, ja.
Dann habe ich amlodipin, 5 Milligramm, 1 morgens.
Ja, und noch rüstig.
Bitte?
Ja, dann habe ich für Zucker noch, ja, Dianz heißt das.
Also ja, Dianz mit J, 10 Milligramm, 1 morgens, ja.
Dann habe ich Metformin, 1000 morgens und abends eine Tablette.
Dann habe ich wegen der COPD, habe ich noch so,
Immunation, sprich, ja Genua, Genua Air, Genua Air, morgens und abends,
Einhub.
Und dann habe ich noch, wenn Luft mal schlechter wird, Salbutamol,
was ich bei Bedarf nehmen, aber es hat nicht geholfen,
jetzt zuletzt.
Und dann habe ich noch wegen Osteobrosa,
Alumin D 1000 und Calcium 1000 Milligramm.
Das war meine Liste.
Ja, gut.
Herr Stauf, das war alles.
Vielen Dank für die Information.
Ja.
Ich würde etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie eine Frage?
Was meinen Sie, Doktor, muss ich im Krankenhaus bleiben
oder kann ich wieder nach Hause gehen?
Das ist früher, aber Ihre bisherige anonystische Angabe
deuten auf eine COPD-Exorvation.
Ist das schlimm?
Ja, das muss ich so als eine diagnostische Massnahme
durchführen, danach sagen.
Früher etwas schwer, aber möglicherweise
Sie müssen bei uns bleiben.
Okay, weil meine Frau braucht auch Mannhilfe,
die ist nicht mehr so ganz gesund deswegen.
Ach ja, also in unserem Haus gibt es eine Sozialdienst, ja?
Ja.
Ich kümmer nur um Ihre Frauen, ich mache sich noch eine Sorge.
Ja?
Ich kann etwas erledigen.
Alles klar, das ist nett vor Ihnen. Vielen Dank.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Seit wann hat der Patient Luftnoten steht im Chat seit 3 Tagen
starke Luftnot.
Sie haben gesagt 2-3 Tage, ja.
Schrafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich habe nicht so gut.
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie zum Schrafen?
1, 1 noch mal.
Ich weiß ausbülen, ja.
Keine Schweißausbrüche?
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihr Körper irgendwelche
eine Luftnoten habt?
Diese Frage können Patienten nicht gut beurteilen,
weil sie meistens nicht wissen,
was Luftnoten sind.
Schwellung?
Schwellung ist besser, ja.
Wir müssen noch sagen, wo Schwellung?
Hauge, Kopf, Hals?
Hals.
Schwellung am Hals, darf da nicht bemerken.
Haben Sie Heiserkeit?
Keine Heiserkeit.
Herzrasen, Herzklopfen.
Ja, wenn er zur Toilette gelaufen hat,
hat er Herzrasen, ja.
Haben Sie Blut gehusstet?
Nein, er hat kein Blut gehusstet.
Schluckbeschwerden?
Nicht, dass es ihm aufgefallen wäre.
Keine Schluckbeschwerden.
Warum fragen Sie nach Schluckbeschwerden?
Husten, eine Nodul, zum Beispiel.
Was können wir noch fragen?
Ich glaube, Sie wollten in eine richtige Richtung gehen,
um zu fragen, ob er Sauros aufstoßen hat,
oder Reflex.
Das kann man auch.
Das kann man noch fragen.
Sind Ihre Beschwerden lagerabhängig?
Sie waren es im Liegen mehr als im Sitzen?
Nicht so richtig, ist beides.
Ist sie entschwindelig, wenn sie laufen?
Also jetzt aktuell ist sie entschwindelig, wenn es läuft, ja.
Ihr hattet ein Tag über, oder?
Seit zwei, drei Tagen auch tagsüber und nachts beides.
Gut, das wären so die wichtigen Fragen.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen als gewesen?
Seit zwei, drei Tagen nicht, nein.
Es kommt direkt ins Krankenhaus, im Krankenwagen.
Okay, das war es.
Geschwollene Bleine haben Sie schon gefragt?
Geschwollene Bleine, unmächtig?
Nein, keine Unmacht.
Enges Gefühl, das ist eine wichtige Frage, ja.
Enges Gefühl, meinen Sie, wo? Im Hals?
Wo ist das denn?
Angina.
Angina hat er nicht gehabt, nein.
Haben Sie Allergien, diese Frage festgestellt?
Gut, eine wichtige Frage, ja.
Gerade, weil, wenn wir jetzt auch an die Biotika denken und so was,
keine Allergien bisher, ist richtig.
Gut, gute Frage.
Was hätte man noch fragen können?
5 Jahre lang haben Sie eingenommen?
Bitte?
Rami Pil.
Seit ungefähr, wie lange?
Seit 10, 15 Jahren hat er Bluthochdruck und Medikamente ein.
Ich vermute, das ist schon so lang ist.
Was kann man aber noch fragen,
gerade wenn Sie jetzt eine Diagnose COPD denken?
Was kann man noch fragen?
Ein Hinblick auf den schwere Grad der COPD.
Also, ein oder auch 70 Jahre alt?
Über 65 Jahre.
Das ist ein richtiges.
Ja, 70 Jahre alt, ja.
Herrs Rasen, ich habe nicht gestellt,
vielleicht das Samstag oder Atemfrequenz.
Was haben Sie mit den Vitalparamitern gemessen,
das erhöht, ja.
Und Sättigung war ungefähr so 89 Prozent.
Am Ende gefragt, ja.
Auszieher ist hier gefragt worden, keine Haustiere.
Hautveränderung gelb so, keine.
lange Strecken gefahren, zum Beispiel mit Auto oder mit Flugzeug.
Wegen Verdacht auf Lungenembolli, glaube ich,
die Frage gehört er nicht gehabt.
Ein oder außeratmen Probleme?
Beides.
Aber was kann man bei COPD noch fragen?
Er erzählt seine Vorgeschichte,
aber was fragt man da gerne?
Auf sich verstanden.
Aber wichtig wäre die Frage,
ob er schon mal so ein Episode hatte
oder wie oft er schon mal diese Probleme hatte.
Ich habe schon ein Ding gesteckt.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Wir haben sie gefragt am Anfang.
Nein, aber ich habe manche krummische Kompilaten gesagt.
Manchmal muss man das genau fragen,
weil oft ist so, dass Sie das fragen,
wenn Sie nach Krankenhaus aufhalten,
waren Sie schon beim Krankenhaus letzten Zeit oder letzten Monat,
letzten Jahr.
Das kann man fragen, manchmal sagen die Patienten nicht.
Wenn Sie sagen nach ähnlichen Beschwerden,
dann ist das schon richtig, dann reicht das aus.
So eine freundliche Erlage.
Einige sind Grippe oder ähnliche Symptome gehabt.
Sollte man auch vielleicht so sagen,
im letzten Jahr vielleicht, weil es ja auch die Frequenz
der Verschlechterung der COPD,
der mit einer Rolle spielt, die Symptomen lasst.
Für die Einteilung.
Was haben wir noch aus,
wie oft diese Erkrankungen jedes Jahr?
Genau, das ist die Frage.
Medikament hat er gesagt.
Leiden Sie schlafen nach dem Taxiüber?
Kann er so nicht sagen, nee.
Haben wir sehr viele Fragen gestellt jetzt, oder?
Ja, können wir als Tatjuschwer am Anfang?
Gerne.
Bitte schön.
Ich bin der Oberarzt jetzt, ja?
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt.
Hätten Sie großer Zeit für mich.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient auch genommen
und möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Gerne, bitte schön.
Francis, Franzis, Franziskus, Strauss.
Franz Josef.
Franz Josef Strauss.
Aber sagen Sie nur, Herr Strauss.
Herr Strauss ist ein 70-jähriger Patient,
der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund.
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Wer sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund,
seit...
Aufgrund, was heißt aufgrund?
Wegen.
In Folge.
Machen Sie noch mal den Satz von vorne.
Okay.
Ich habe einen 70-jährigen Patient,
der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund,
seit zweit...
Es geht nicht.
Was haben Sie gesagt, vorgestellt oder aufgenommen wurde?
Eins von beiden.
Wegen, vorgestellt oder mit...
Also ich kann den Satz noch mal wiederholen, ganz langsam.
Herr Strauss ist ein 70-jähriger Patient,
der sich heute Morgen bei uns aufgrund,
seit zwei, drei Tagen bestehende,
nötzlich auftretende Hüsten
mit gelblich, grünlich,
schleimigen Auswurz vorgestellt hat.
Okay, so ist perfekt.
So ist gut.
Dispne, den mal, wir haben mal Anasemton dispne.
Nein, das ist ja ein bisschen nirgisch,
aber der Satz war gut, Husten plus Luftnot.
Ja, auch dispne, so wie Dispne vorgestellt hat.
Ja.
Der Patient berichtet, dass sich Beschwerter
vorher nicht erlebt haben,
aber seit drei Tagen,
so nehmen, so nehmen sie.
Okay, habe ich es richtig verstanden,
dass der vor drei Tagen überhaupt keine Luftnot hatte?
Ja.
Sie haben es noch gesagt.
Nein, so ist nicht gewesen.
Er hat vorher auch schon Probleme lange mit der Luft gehabt, hat er gesagt.
Weil das würde diese ganze Anamnese in eine andere Richtung drängen, wissen Sie?
Wenn sagt vorher überhaupt keine Probleme
mit der Luftnot, dann ist es eine andere Diagnose-Schiene.
Genau, Sie haben recht, aber
ähnliche Symptome, Sie haben vorher nicht.
Er hat aber gesagt, dass er schon sehr lange Probleme mit der Luft hat.
Ja.
Leider an, Leider an,
die Leber habe schon.
Dann müssen Sie im Obatz sagen,
dass der Patient schon seit längerer Zeit Probleme mit der Luft hat,
wegen der COPD, aber seit zweiter Tagen,
die sich deutlich verschlechtert hat.
Ja.
Mit Hustenauswurf, grünlich-gelblich, haben Sie gesagt, ja.
Mhm.
Zusätzlich teilt er mit,
bei Bewegung,
bei Beweging,
bei Bewegung
zusätzlich teilt er mit,
dass die Beschwerden
lagerabhängig sein.
Und wenn Sie
lange Strecke laufen
möchten,
sich verschlimmen.
Okay.
Darf ich auch noch mal ganz kurz korrigieren?
Die Schwerden sind nicht lagerabhängig.
Das ist ja, das ist,
lagerabhängig bezieht sich immer auf Liegensitzn stehen.
Bewegung,
vielleicht geht noch besser.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen, Sie können es besser sagen,
dass die Beschwerden dazu führen,
dass eine Düsbne schon bei geringster Belastung,
zum Beispiel der Weg zur Toilette, auftritt.
Ja.
Wichtig bei geringster Belastung kann man vielleicht immer sagen,
geringster Belastung.
Die vegetative Anämnese
ist unauffällig,
bis auf Inappetanz
seit drei Tagen
Abschlagenheit.
Ja, die beiden.
Ja.
Der Patient
seit Rauchen, seit
fünf Jahren habe er auch gehört,
Rauchen zu rauchen.
Aber vorher habe er
fünf, 30 Jahre
täglich
30s, Digaretten geraucht.
Das entspricht
sechs,
das
fünf,
40 päkend Jahre.
Er hat gesagt,
er hat mit 15 angefangen
und vor fünf Jahren, der war 65 Jahre alt.
Ich habe gesagt, vor fünf Jahren.
Da war er auch gehört,
so Rauchen.
Wie alt war er vor fünf Jahren?
Sechsundfünfzig.
War er da angefangen?
Nein.
Er hat angefangen mit wieviel Jahren?
Er habe vor 30 Jahren geraucht.
Er hat nicht recht,
von 15 bis 65, das ist mehr als 30 Jahre.
Mit 15 Jahren angefangen
und bis 65 Jahre geraucht.
Wie viele Jahre sind das?
Das macht 50 Jahre.
Das habe ich mal gelesen.
Ich habe 50 Jahre geschrieben.
Aber 30 Jahre habe ich genannt.
Sie haben sich verwechselt.
Seit 50 Jahren geraucht.
Zigaretten täglich.
Das entspricht
75 päkend.
Er trinkt täglich ein Bier.
Aber in der Lesterzeit trinke er selbst.
Er konstituiert keine Drogen.
Er ist in Besuch
Medikamentennehmer.
Er ist in der Saison.
Er setzt 100 potassium.
Es ist täglich ein morgens.
Es sind 20 Gramm.
10 Milligramm täglich einmal morgen.
Nicht vor 1000, täglich zweimal morgen und Abend.
Genova, eh täglich zweimal morgen und Abend Einruf.
Und Salbutamol bei Bedach.
Vitamin D und Calcium 1000 Milligramm.
Gegen noch der Groß, Nehme Eau.
Als Vorkrankungen, leider, wir passieren an.
COPD seit 10 Jahren.
Und ich habe vor fünf Jahren eine Myocardinfarktik erlitten.
Und dagegen eine Stand, der schützt.
Normal?
Stand schützt.
Er hat einen Stand erhalten, oder eingesetzt, zu meinen Sie vielleicht.
Haben wir es nicht erhalten, Stand erhalten.
Ja.
Also seit über 10 Jahren, 8 Jahre, Tipper Tunny.
Dagegen, habe ich schon gesagt, dass wir.
Und seit 7, 8 Jahren, leider ja an, Diabetes Melitus.
Er sei vollständig geriert.
Und vor einem Jahr habe der Patient seine.
Länden wie Belsäule 5 gebrochen.
Eine Fraktur von LBS 5 gehabt.
Aber Nonoperativ Behandlung.
Er hat, er habe er gehabt.
Konservativ Behandlung.
Als Kind war, sei er 13 oder so ein Innalter von 13, 14 Jahren.
Sei der Patient Appendeptum durchgeführt.
Er sei vollständig geriert.
Er treibe keinen Sport.
Und als Familienanlese, oder die Familienanlese,
gibt es ungenössig sein Vater, leider,
an Wundentraps gestorben.
Und seine Mutter, an Apopleks gestorben.
Er habe zwei Schwester, aber keine Kontakte mit ihnen.
Er sei verheiratet, aber keine Kinder.
So sei er Rentner, aber vorher als Lage gearbeitet.
Langes seit, als Lage, mit Lage arbeiten.
Lagearbeiter gearbeitet, kann man auch sagen.
Das war alles.
Was ist bei der Diagnose?
Die anonystischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auch
die Exorbation, als Differenzial Diagnose entkommen.
Lungenembolie, oder Lungenkrebs,
oder Herzinstituzienz im Betracht,
als Differenzial Diagnose bestätigen.
Und die Differenzial Diagnose aufzuschließen.
Es wird eine etropelische Untersuchung
im Blut abnehmen und Ultraschalt durchführen.
EKG durchführen, beschreiben,
gegebenen Rücken aufnehmen,
gegebenen Torachs CT, erforderlich.
Sie haben jetzt zehn Patienten auskultiert.
Was haben Sie gehört?
Ja, ich habe den Patient abgehört.
Was hört man bei COPD?
Man kann auskultieren.
Wie ist das Atemgeräusch?
Ich habe das gehört.
Was ist das normaler Atemgeräusch?
Wie beschreibt man ein normales Atemgeräusch?
Normaler Atemgeräusch ist
eine Erkrankung,
eine Erkrankung zum Krankenhaus dogs,
na pa,
na pa, na pa, na pa, na pa.
Wir haben eine Erkrankung,
eine Erkrankung,
eine Erkrankung ...
Da sagt man dazu,
ein vesikuläres Atemgeräusch,
nicht Merci.
ist oft abgeschwächt, Atemgeräusche.
Ist das aber, da gibt es auch bei Sontora eine Atemgeräusche?
Ja, das Atemgeräusch ist abgeschwächt in dem Fall, abgefäßt Atemgeräusche.
Oder man sagt auch Silent Chests, weil manche mal gar nichts hören kann, Atemgeräusche.
Abgeschwächtes Atemgeräusch.
Und dann gibt es aber auch Nebengeräusche von der Lunge, die nennt man wie?
Rasselgeräusche.
Welche Krankheiten?
Egal, man hat, man hat, man hat Atemgeräusche, das ist entweder vesikulär, abgeschwert oder verschärft.
Die drei, die drei Kategorien gibt es ja.
Vesikulär ist normal.
Abgeschwächt, zum Beispiel bei Pneumonie auch, wenn die Lichtbelüfter die Lunge, oder zum Beispiel Ergus.
Ein verschärftes Atemgeräusch, zum Beispiel dann die Effektration.
Was kann man auch hören?
Bitte.
Rasselgeräusche.
Jetzt kommen die Rasselgeräusche.
Das ist das Atemgeräusch.
Dann gibt es Nebengeräusche, die nennt man Rasselgeräusche.
Die sind pathologisch.
Was für Rasselgeräusche kennen Sie?
Das ist ein Bruschelatmen.
Ja, das können wir.
Ob einmal die Rasselgeräusche...
Das ist ein zweiteil Einteil.
In feuchter Rasselgeräusche und trockener Rasselgeräusche.
Ja.
Das sind die Rasselgeräuschen, die in der Regel bei Infiltrativänder und der Lunge zu hören.
Also zum Beispiel bei Pneumonie oder auch bei Lungenödem.
Das sind feuchter Rasselgeräusche.
Und da gibt es sich auch die trockenen Rasselgeräusche.
Dazu gehören zum Beispiel Giemen, Brummen, Pfeifen.
Das ist typisches Geräusch, was man bei Asthma oder COPD hören kann.
Trockene Rasselgeräusche.
Oder können auch sagen, Giemen, Brummen.
Manchmal durch diese Schleimfäden, die in den Brunchal, Lumen, hin und her wandern.
Also typisches Ausstationsbefund bei COPD-Patienten,
exterzi-feder COPD-Patienten,
ist abgeschweigtes Atemgeräusch und trockene Rasselgeräusche,
wenn man etwas hört.
Beispiel Giemen und Brummen.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie ihn abgehört.
Sie hören fast nichts, Zeilen und Chests.
Was machen Sie dann? Haben Sie gesagt?
Man Röntgenbild, ja, ist richtig.
Ja, man Röntgenbild.
Wir haben vorher aber schon die Vitalparameter.
Ultraschall, auch können wir durchspüren.
Ultraschall von was, wenn ich fragen darf.
Also Torachbereichkönnung wie der Schale.
Wegen Ergust oder warum?
Ja, genau.
Und Sie haben ja schon vorher eine Blutgasanalyse gemacht,
die Teilparameter.
Haben Sie bestimmt schon oder noch nicht?
Oder Sie haben Pulsoksymetrie gemacht.
Der nächste Schritt wäre,
eine Blutgasanalyse zu machen bei den Patienten.
Ja, genau.
Und dann hat jemand reingeschrieben,
noch sehe ich gerade Lungenfunktion.
Ist das richtig oder ist das falsch?
Doch, das ist richtig.
Das habe ich vergessen.
Ja, das ist richtig.
In der idealen Welt ist es richtig,
aber wenn Sie diesen Patienten haben,
der schon bei kleinsten Bewegungen zur Toilette
keine Luft mehr hat,
schafft er eine Lungenfunktionsprüfung?
Das schafft er nicht.
Aber jetzt in Akkutstattel schafft er nicht.
Er schafft Akkutstattel und Kraftstattel,
keine Lungenfunktion.
Lungenfunktion ist jetzt keine Untersuchung,
die man akut vor allem machen kann
bei solchen Patienten.
Das ist ja auch ein Problem.
Das kann man gut vor allem machen bei solchen Patienten.
Deswegen machen wir eine Blutgasanalyse.
Blutgasanalyse ist wichtig,
damit man eine Hypoxemie und eine Hypercapnia
auch verstellen kann.
EKG haben sich schon gesagt,
Rhydraschall ist gut und Röntgenbild.
Das ist nur die Basidiagnostik.
Aber Sie haben mir gesagt,
Sie haben Verdacht auf eine Exerzipation
der COPD.
Das ist dann auch wichtig,
wenn man Verdacht auf Exerzipation hat.
Wie passiert denn eine Exerzipation?
Es gibt auch Infektionskrankheiten dabei.
Was macht man da?
Wir versuchen
zu untersuchen
eine Infektionszeichnung.
Fiber, Leuchastus,
andere Infektionsparameter.
Was macht man noch gerne,
wenn man Verdacht auf Infektion hat?
CRP, Blut,
Uswindigkeit.
Hat er alles.
Es gibt auch eine Infektionskrankheit.
Was macht man da?
Was ist die Consequenz?
Wenn Sie eine hohe Infektionsparameter haben,
Rökonzytrose, CRP,
wenn es hoch ist,
dann braucht der Patient
auch Antibiotika.
In dem Fall wird man Antibiotika geben.
Bei dem Alter, dem Ausvorwärts,
Antibiotischtherapie.
Was macht man da?
Es gibt auch eine Infektionsparameter.
Antibiotischtherapie.
Was macht man da,
bevor man Antibiotischtherapie beginnt?
Wie kann man sagen,
ob Antibiotika auch richtig sind?
Hier können wir nicht sofort entscheiden,
oder einteilen,
welche
Erregung da steht.
Wir müssen
als Amprichentherapie
anfangen,
aber gleichzeitig,
wenn es
Fieber gibt,
der Patient,
gleichzeitig
können wir auch eine Blutkultur machen.
Auch eine Sputkultur.
Bei ihm wäre das
Sputkultur sinnvoll,
weil er jetzt keine Fieber gehabt hat.
Kann man zwar trotzdem Blutkultur abnehmen,
aber erst mal Sputkultur,
wenn man das kann.
Okay,
jetzt haben Sie
in Stadt zu dir aufgenommen,
dass der Risikofaktor ist alt,
hat starke Symptome.
Was machen Sie noch mit den Patienten,
außer Diagnostik
und Antibiotiktherapie?
Also,
man muss auch
überprüft werden,
wie ist die Bluttochterung
und
die Blutzuppe?
Ja,
nur bezogen auf uns zu weit,
nur bezogen auf die
Blutzuppe.
Was für Maßnahmen ergreifen Sie noch?
Also,
muss man auch
eine Glüssigkeit geben.
Muss man, kann man?
Muss man, ja.
Nicht unbedingt, ne?
Wenn er genug trinkt,
dann auch so.
Diesen Faller
habe ich keine Inappetanz,
vielleicht.
Er habe auch, klar,
eine Glüssigkeit verloren.
Hat er nicht, ne?
Aber
möglicherweise
er habe eine Tauschipne,
deswegen, ich habe das nicht gefreut,
deswegen
sind dann auch
in den
in Sibyl
eine Glüssigkeit verloren.
Warum ist Physika wichtig
oder könnte wichtig sein?
Warum?
Weil es
viele,
vielfältige chronischen Krankheiten,
die Nierenwerte
könnte nicht spekulieren.
Er hat jetzt nur das, was Sie jetzt erfasst haben
und Sie
haben jetzt nicht ein anderes Problem.
Sie nehmen
so viele verschiedene
Medikamenten.
Da gibt es ein paar Nierentoxiken
oder
Lebertoxiken.
Warum ist
Physika trotzdem manchmal wichtig,
wenn Sie nicht genug trinken die Patienten?
Wenn Sie trinken, kein Problem.
Was ist
mit dem Schleim
Auswurf?
Was ist das Wichtigste bei Schleim
und Auswurf?
Wir können auch gleichzeitig
eine
Mocholite geben.
Wie wirken Mocholite am besten?
Mit Wasser.
Richtig.
Manche sagen sogar,
dass Mocholite gar nichts weckt,
sondern nur das Wasser hilft.
Wenn Sie nicht viel trinken,
dann Infusionen oder sonst nicht.
Warum muss es nicht unbedingt Infusionen geben?
Aber es gibt noch ein paar Gemeinmaßnahmen,
die Sie machen können,
wegen der Extraterbation.
Antibiotika ist wichtig.
Was geben Sie noch dem Patienten?
Hat schon jemand den Chat reingeschrieben?
Man kann auch mit
Kochsalt inhalieren lassen,
damit der Schleim besser abgeht.
Die bräunen sich ja weiter.
Was Sie auch schon gemacht haben,
ganz am Anfang,
hat er gefragt,
Sauerstoffgabe,
wenn die Blutgase schlecht sind.
Worauf müssen Sie achten,
wenn Sie den Patienten Sauerstoff geben?
Bei COPD-Patienten?
Das ist nicht so.
Auch müssen wir nicht so schnell
eine Sauerstoff geben.
Das ist etwas
ein bisschen
gefährlich.
Auch arrumpenwertlich.
Warum ist das gefährlich?
Man könnte
die
rumpenwertlich.
Also kann der
hat
eine Sauerstoff-Gabe
in der
Luft.
Hat nichts mit der Schnelligkeit zu tun.
Sie können dem Patienten gleich mal
so, wenn der Luft und hat viel Sauerstoff geben.
Genau, CO2-Retention
über Capni ist die
Gefahr, die man im Hinterkopf
haben muss.
Sehr gut.
Was gibt es noch für allgemeine
Maßnahmen, wenn man jetzt
patientenstationär behandelt?
Antibiotika, Mucolytika,
Infusion haben Sie auch gegeben.
Was kann man noch machen?
Sauerstoff haben wir.
Vielleicht
Physiotherapie.
Genau.
Wir haben Physiotherapie, Atemgymnasie.
Wenn er nicht besser wird,
schweren Fall, Brettensolon.
Was kann man noch machen, wenn er nicht besser wird?
Wenn der Patient
zunehmend schlechter von den
Blutgasen wird
oder die Ventilation.
Was machen Sie dann?
Teophilien.
Medikamente können Sie auf jeden Fall probieren.
Qualicosteriöde auch.
Aber ich denke noch etwas anderes.
Intubieren.
Aber vorher kann man noch etwas anderes machen,
bevor man intubiert.
Sie opinionen.
Man kann sagen,
nicht-invasive Beatmung.
Nicht-invasive Ventilation.
Also Zepap oder so.
Genau.
Okay.
Das wären die wichtigsten Sachen,
die Sie auch schon gefragt haben.
Sie haben nach dem Impfschutz gefragt.
Da hat er aber nur Corona gesagt.
Das reicht aber nicht aus bei den Patienten.
Worauf müssen Sie noch fragen,
wenn Sie Impfschutz wissen wollen
bei den Patienten?
Vielleicht die Difterie.
Difterie nicht.
Aber es gibt andere Krankheiten,
die bei ZIOP oder Lungenlangen haben.
Bitte welche noch einmal?
Mit Kapselentvaterien.
Das ist wichtig.
Meine Impfung ist wichtig.
Pneumonie-Räde.
Welche?
Pneumokokken.
Neufelows-Inflernse.
Genau.
Pneumokokken ist wichtig.
Was impfen Sie noch?
Was sollten Sie impfen, empfehlen?
Einmal pro Jahr noch.
Ja, Krieg für Krieg.
Einmal für die Influencer-Virus.
Im Flernse-Virus.
Influencer, genau.
Das ist einmal pro Jahr.
Und die Pneumokokken machen alle 5-6 Jahre.
Gut, dann haben wir ziemlich
vielen an Therapeuten-Masterm empfohlen.
Noxenkarenz, ja, ist richtig.
Wenn der Patient raucht,
muss er aufhören zu rauchen.
Aber er hat ja schon aufgehört,
gerade zum Glück.
Gibt es noch weitere Kommentare?
Ich gehe mal schnell den Chapter mal durch.
Atemfrequenz-Blutbild haben wir alles gesagt.
In der Lationstherapie sei betamen Mundvernebler.
Jawohl.
Reparaturium kann man auch machen.
CO2 hatten wir angesprochen.
Atemgymnastik, schwere Verlebräder,
Prätnesolon, Theofilines,
auch ein Reservimedikament.
Corticosteroetcepap,
nicht massive Bahnenpantilation,
Pneumokrippe.
Ich denke Diuretik.
Bitte?
Warum Diuretika?
Diese Patienten sind 70 Jahre alt
und meistens zusammen in der Krankheit.
Herzkrankheit, Hypertonie, COPD, alles.
Jetzt machen Sie das gleiche wie der Kollege.
Er sagt, Flüssigkeit geben und Diuretik.
Jetzt müssen Sie entscheiden.
Wollen Sie abstimmen oder was?
Die beiden gehen auch.
Jetzt bringen Sie den Patienten um.
An der gibt Flüssigkeit, an der gibt Diuretika.
Ich habe viele Jahre erfahren
und die Diuretik haben.
und diese Patienten
nicht nur COPD-Exzitervation,
sondern auch Reitwärtsentwicklung
in Science
und Hypertonie.
Aber nicht spekulieren,
sondern wissen.
Nicht Erfahrung, sondern wissen.
Da müssen Sie nach entsprechenden Sachen
gucken.
Borbe hat Echokardiografie und so weiter.
Vorher würde ich nicht mehr.
Nicht auf der Dach machen.
Sie haben gesagt,
welche Medikamente
was denken Sie?
Ich denke Diuretik.
Er sagt Infusion.
Was jetzt?
Er hat recht.
Also keine Spekulation.
Nur nach Befund.
Wenn er keine Herz- und Szenenzeichen hat,
keine Diuretika.
Warum?
Medikamente sind mehr Komplikationen.
Wenn noch eine Diuretika gibt
noch eine Embolie
oder werden die in der Rumbose auch schlecht?
Meistens.
Ich habe schon gesagt meistens.
Meistens, aber
der sagt meistens.
Aber nicht
einhundert wichtig,
aber meistens.
Man muss sagen,
bei so einem Gespräch,
wenn Zeichen bestehen,
auch der Herzenswizienz,
sollte man auch an Diuretika denken.
Man muss immer Diplomatik formulieren.
Wenn der Prüfer sagt,
das ist schwach sind,
dann lässt er sie durchfallen wegen so ein Mist.
Eine Kleinigkeit.
Nicht sagen, ich habe Erfahrung.
Das ist immer die schlechteste Antwort.
Herr Dr. Gündis.
Weil er sagt, da habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Dann ist er eingeschnappt.
Wie ich.
Also immer Vorschläge machen.
Man könnte überlegen.
Immer Diplomatik.
Aber das ist ja nicht so.
Einfach verstanden.
Ich denke nicht.
Ja, alles klar.
Gut.
Also, das sehe ich gerade im Chat.
Das ist heftige Diskussion, ob wir Schwierigkeiten geben.
Ich denke, wir lassen es mal hier dabei bewenden.
Weder noch.
Alles klar.
Gut, weitere Kommentare.
War komplex heute oder nicht so komplex?
Nicht so komplex.
Ich muss wissen.